and usually do you have a a 20 minutes a
day twice a day what is your regimen
yeah I try to do it twice a day for 20
minutes each time usually before
breakfast and before dinner um but I'm
not uh perfect uh you know I would say
probably uh a third of the time I do it
twice a day a third of the time I do it
once a day and a third of the day days I
I I miss it um but there's times where I
could just feel I just want to go medit
I feel ah it'll just make me feel so
good and I get that pull so I can it
could be any time of the day almost on
any set of circumstances because it's
very refreshing and relaxing it's almost
like going on a vacation it's a tool
that you use and I love what you just
described too so many people get so
rigid then they start judging themselves
about it and they're get red and the
meditation becomes about something else
so I'm really it's nice of you to share
that there's a variety of how this works
it's really based on what serves and
needs but there is a consistency that's
allowed you to continually find that
balance in your life